hundreds of people in Las Vegas have
been lining up to donate blood some
volunteers told us yesterday that they
waited eight hours in line Carter Evans
is outside University Medical Center in
Las Vegas where many of the victims are
being treated Carter good morning good
morning the University Medical Center is
the only level 1 trauma center in Nevada
and the ambulances were just streaming
in here Sunday night one after one but
they weren't the only ones bringing in
critically injured patients as gunfire
erupted concert goers who were not
injured became first responders moving
victims to safety in wheelbarrows office
chairs and hotel luggage carts Tom
McIntosh was shot in a leg and rescued
by a stranger open up the tailgate on
some truck and turn me in there and and
took my belt and tied my leg off and
basically
he saved my life victims were rushed to
five Southern Nevada hospitals
University Medical Center treated more
than 100 patients these patients were so
many coming in so fast we did what's
called damage control which is really
just stopping the process of dying
trauma surgeon Jay Coates says they
trained for situations like this have
you ever experienced anything like that
no this is the largest mass casualty
I've ever been involved in this is a
well-oiled machine
KO's colleague Tony Mullen a clinical
nurse supervisor got the call around
9:30 p.m. after her shift was over to
come back to the trauma center she said
the patient's just kept coming every
death means something every death
touches us when these patients were
coming in the loss of life that we were
hearing was so grave we just go into
emotion that we do what we need to do
now the hospital says a few months ago
the staff here actually met with a
doctor who treated patients after the
pulse nightclub shooting well the staff
was able to learn able to use some of
what they learned from that doctor
on Sunday night Norah incredible Carter
thank you so much